is there a way to be a yes-man to say
yes but without being a pushover and
without compromising your integrity your
beliefs your deadlines all of that how
do you be collaborative but still you
know steer the ship well there was the
yes-man thing has been a lot to do with
taking on projects I remember when I
said no to my first project and it was
it was only about a year ago actually
maybe slightly longer that I fern
somebody asked if I could do something
and I I just said I and I went away and
I came back to said oh I'm sorry I don't
really have time I did consult with a
mentor of mine and I said look I'm sorry
I don't have time to do it but then when
you're in the project the key thing is
knowing what I want ah here we come
Kevin Spacey swimming with sharks what
do you want
lastly says what do you want he says to
this guy who's worked in inhale as a
year whatever as his assistant to make
it up the Hollywood chain whatever
I'm sure it's heavily fictionalized and
make believe that you know he um what do
you want and the guy can't answer him I
remember while watching that movie I
don't know the answer to that this was
this was years ago I first saw I've
watched it since the thing is now when I
do a project okay a lot of the projects
that I have idea sleek die the ones that
live I know I want okay and when that
project starts I know what the heart of
it is I said said this in another the
question you asked me you know I I I
know what I want
because it's at the heart of the project
it's the idea it's the violin with the
subatomic particles it's the opera
singer trading stocks you know it's the
son playing the building as a musical
interests or well it rises that's what I
want everything else can be done around
it if you want to change that you know
so far no one has made me change the
heart and I don't know if that's me I
don't know if that's because I've
defined the projects well at the
beginning but if someone did make me do
that
here's an interesting thing
I have had to do fights too but it would
depend who it was if one of my mentors
told me you have got to change the heart
of this project I mean I'm so fortunate
in my position and the people I've got
supporting me there's a handful of
people who they could stay could
actually say to me you've got to change
the heart of this project and I would do
it because all this myth about the
self-sustaining artist you know not the
root I'm going down you know I am
dependent on a number of people so I
would I would compromise because I know
I wouldn't have to compromise forever if
I had to compromise every project you
know I'd start to lose what makes what
I'm doing you need you know I hate to
test sound unfashionable that but the
truth is I'm damn lucky to be doing what
I'm doing and I'd be well it's doing
something I'm damned slightly less
interesting why I'm doing it still be
really interesting alright and I'm aware
of that so I know that I could
compromise quite a long way with what I
do and still feel incredibly fortunate
to be what I'm doing to be doing what
I'm doing and so so on the one side
there's that part of me and I think
that's a sign of maturity you know
because when you realize when I realize
how fortunate I am to be doing what I'm
doing and even doing half of what I'm
doing I'm not going to jeopardize it by
allowing my character flaws to run riot
you know so that's that's one part of it
but at the same time I think that people
do seem to value at the moment the
hearts that I've developed for the
projects so I am able so they don't seem
to want to you know they they will let
me defend it they won't draw a line in
the sand and say you have to change the
heart of that project although there
hasn't happened to me and I think it
will happen rarely as long as I can be
flexible and it's another of those
questions and other of those things in
the article erm play your cards right it
talks about never be satisfied because I
think the minute I just start doing a
carbon copy you know and maybe at first
people
when realize it's a carbon core I will
if I just start doing a carbon copy of
everything eventually you know other
people will will it'll lose that that
that power that enables me to have a
heart that people don't try to to cut or
change or make me compromise in it and
it will give me the passion that when
that does happen I can defend it but you
know I am NOT somebody who wants to live
starving in a tiny studio flat just
doing the thing that I believe is
artistically brilliant because I don't
think I I don't think I am artistically
brilliant I think I'm good at what I do
I think I'm good at my little bit but
you know I don't think I'm there there
are some people who are just brilliant
amazing historically amazing and maybe
they're the ones that can get away with
being isolated from the world and from
society and from reality because the
work they do is just so amazing that it
will survive but even maybe that's a
myth I don't know
you